[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Галичина,
Львів]
Хотів собі наплічник купити якийсь класний,
але дуже дорого було.
Я пішов собі й думаю: «Так, класно.
Грошей нема».
Ну й тоді я подумав, що можна спробувати пошити.
Але в мене тоді не вийшло.
З першого разу, з другого не вийшло.
З третього не вийшло.
Я був такий в печалі.
Гадав, що нічого не гідний у житті.
Потім в мене таки вийшов наплічник.
[Сашко Горонді,
засновник бренду Horondi]
Я почав з ним ходити по місту.
Почали питатися люди, що за наплічник.
Було видно, що він не з магазину.
Воно було зліплено з чогось, незрозуміло з чого.
І так почали в мене
замовляти наплічники.
Починав з секонду.
Я купляв якісь куртки й шив з того.
Так я почав працювати, працювати, працювати.
100500 разів були невдачі.
А зараз ми шиємо вдвох,
і це дуже круто.
Коли я був у Мукачеві,
я був у такій компанії,
де були молодші, середні й старші.
Молодші носили гроші середнім,
а середні — старшим.
І ми мусили постійно, кожен день,
грабувати людей чи ще щось.
Зараз мені важко це казати.
До тебе додому могла пхати поліція.
Потім мені ще дали судимість.
Це був такий дзвіночок.
Ну і я пам'ятаю, як поліцейський мені казав:
«Ти або тікай з міста, або ви усі тут сядете».
Ну я не знав, Львів — що це за місто.
Я тоді сів на електричку,
на найближчу, яка була по графіку.
В мене було тоді 20 гривень,
я пам'ятаю.
Я приїхав до Львова
і не знав, що це за місце.
Просто вийшов на кінцевій станції на вокзалі.
Я взагалі не виходив тоді за межі Привокзальної.
Бо я боявся виходити.
Так пройшли перші три дні,
я шлявся по вокзалу.
В мене знову був вибір:
або йти красти...
Тобто я думав йти працювати,
шукати роботу,
але я мав судимість тоді.
В мене була купа стереотипів, що у мене судимість,
що мене ніхто не візьме.
На Привокзальній там бабусі
продають всілякі речі.
Вони сказали мені про місце,
куди можна здавати книжки, посуд, одяг.
І вони тобі за це одразу живі гроші давали.
Якісь там копійки, але це були гроші.
Ну і все, мій день полягав в тому,
що я обходив 5-7 смітників,
кожен день так ходив...
«Оселя» — це міжнародна організація,
яка займається реструктуризацією
і поверненням бездомних в соціум.
Я потрапив туди з вулиці.
З нічліжки.
Я часом ночував там —
колись давно, в 17 років.
Зараз мені 27.
Я не повинен був.
Мене важко віднести себе
до бездомних.
Тому що я жив на вулиці три місяці.
Я встиг як раз не звикнути до вулиці.
І мені легко було потім повернутися у соціум.
Спочатку я не хотів, думав,
що це якась сектантська штука.
Взагалі в мене не було
такої моделі в голові,
що хтось може комусь
щось просто так дати безкоштовно.
Я знав тільки один інстинкт, якого мене навчили.
І так я в «Оселі» почав жити.
Це така спільнота,
в якій один одного підтримують,
створюють сім'ю,
заводять друзів.
Бездомні люди працюють,
мають спільні кошти.
І ті кошти потім розподіляються.
Тобто, кожен розуміє, що від нього залежить,
що він завтра буде їсти,
які він буде мати кишенькові.
Їх ніхто не фінансує.
Вони живуть від того, що вони напрацюють.
Для мене це було круто.
В перший день мені дали лопату в руки.
Це була зима, і мені сказали:
«Йди чисти сніг на вулиці».
Шийні машинки були «оселівські»,
й вечорами я сидів після роботи шив.
Пробував, вчився.
Потім на цю машинку мені позичили гроші.
Я часто ставлю собі питання:
«Чому я пішов цим шляхом?»
Бо мені було дуже важко, я пам'ятаю.
Я постійно в мінусі був.
Я перестав боятися піднімати ціни.
А також я почав кращі моделі робити,
тому люди почали більше замовляти.
Я дав собі раду завдяки тим людям, що були поряд.
Я би міг зараз теж якось працювати в тому руслі.
Давати раду таким людям, як я колись був.
В день приблизно два рюкзаки шию.
Один-два.
Мене процес затягує з ранку й до вечора.
Мене скоро через це друзів не буде.
Бо я з ними не бачуся, тільки в підвалі сиджу.
Не знаю, для мене це іноді як терапія.
Я не відчуваю ані втоми,
ані того, що я на роботі.
Для мене це — не робота.
Багато почали з-за кордону замовляти.
А по суті дехто взагалі мене не знає.
Вони просто приїжджають, пишуть через друзів.
Але це, знову ж таки, було хоббі.
Коли я починав й вечорами шив наплічники,
я тоді взагалі ще нічого не заробляв.
Але попри все мені подобалося це робити.
[aвтор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[oператори
Павло Пашко, Макс Завалля]
[продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[режисер
Микола Носок]
[звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[монтажерка
Альона Воробйова]
[музика
Патроничі, Гапочка]